because if this does go wrong hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to at
dead of night we just got done watching
the whole hotel burn down
with jimmy in the basement so now we
need to go upstairs
check where we're gonna go i i'll be
right back i may have just remember
nated
my way to success because i think
i went to the first floor instead of no
judging by that spinning
do nothing nothing no okay it's not here
okay
never mind sorry i'll be back okay so i
just need to go to two
boo we made it back to two found out
that two is where we need to be
so we just need mosey i don't hear
anybody
that's a good sign usually
now if i could just just get my door
hello oh here
oh yeah oh yeah
hello
i mean they all look familiar i was
about to say i i think i've been here
before no no right
hello anybody here
hello
it might be around the corner on the
other side it may not be exactly here
hmm because if this does go right oh
we're going down
i don't wanna get out of the hotel oh
okay
this is my hotel get out of my hotel
okay hey buddy hey what's up man um
you all right yeah you okay
was that jamie hey uh harvey
is it harvey harvey
hey uh so i saw you with a gun there
saw you with a gun i saw you with a gun
practicing with it
what were you going to do oh practicing
oh okay
[Music]
what wasn't he a child isn't
well i guess he was kind of a dangerous
child but isn't he a child is that what
the crossbow was for
when you said you didn't realize jimmy
would be armed too does that have
anything to do with what you said about
the crossbow
i don't know if that's true because
there's there's some other link
yeah okay there's got to be some other
link besides that um
armed washing line why was there a
washing line tied around a rolling pin i
didn't ask about that
oh don't know okay weird all right so i
don't think that i have anything else
besides
well maybe the sword sword
does it have something to do with the
sword when you said you didn't realize
jimmy would be armed too
does that have anything to do with what
he said about the sword
ah all right fine whatever okay i'm just
gonna scry
whoa i'm gonna scry
tell me the secrets of how jimmy
managed to uh kill harvey
although i'm assuming judging by what's
been happening
that jimmy isn't actually going to end
up killing anybody
not saying that jimmy is totally
blameless okay 206.
all right so we just got to get past if
jimmy is around
which he might be
oh my god what the hell what in the hell
what
what the hell
[Music]
what in the hell
[Music]
no one's here scootaloo
he's gonna he's gonna bash my brains in
[Music]
oh no he did not i'm waiting though
you are a sneaky son of a [ __ ] and i'm
not i'm not going to be caught with my
pants down
not again i'm going to wait a little bit
longer because i want to ring it
ah it's fine it's fine it's fine it's
fine it's fine okay all right i don't
know what that was about
but kind of weird kind of weird
yeah uh-huh yo what's up
what's up man ooh wait oh no i don't
have any keys anymore i can't go through
the other door on the other side of this
anyway
that's a whole lot of useless that's
useless to me
i don't hear any footsteps oh wait let
me dip
dipping
all right whatever i'm going
if i die i'd die but i'm gonna stop
cowering in fear
okay i need to get to 206.
okay
okay so he's far away so
this is the way back i believe
yeah okay
so i think i needed to go to the other
side to get to 206. yeah i did
don't like that sound that's bad music
i'm just gonna go quickly down and then
up and i'm gonna go around
i was probably fine i was probably
totally fine i was probably 100 fine you
remember how i said i wasn't going to be
a coward
i lied
[Music]
[Music]
oh god oh god oh god
he really is camping out exactly where i
need to be done he all right i'm just
gonna go
aha okay
so he's the son of a [ __ ] i wonder if i
like
call him in the ground floor
and then i go up the stairs to like
floor one
and then take floor one to floor two
if that would do anything for me jimmy
hey hmm
probably is not gonna do anything for me
but anything at this point
i hear the music though i do hear that
music
oh but god dawg do i not i don't know
i don't have that key god
i okay i just gotta do the the levators
probably fine number two i'm just gonna
go for it i'll just go for it you there
[ __ ]
you there [ __ ] oh you are there [ __ ]
well i'm not gonna go there i'm gonna go
here idiot you fool you fool
oh [ __ ] oh god oh no okay all right well
god damn it okay um i'm just gonna go
ahead and go to the
here and then we wait
okay sounds like he's kind of far away
so i got a little bit of a window here
i'm gonna go
i'm just gonna wait here though
okay what do i hear
[Music]
well that sounded close
you there buddy you're there buddy
are you there buddy you better not be
there buddy oh my god you better not be
there
i'm so stressed i'm going
okay so this was 204 205.
206.
okay so he's farther away what
room is this what is this one that's 201
okay so it must be down that way
that's it the one got it
oh a dagger so it wasn't the sword it
was the dagger
okay that's okay ah 206
i'm gonna i'm gonna deadlock this room
i'm so deadlocking it i'm so
deadlocking you you're getting dead
locked
oh god oh god oh god
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] try it [ __ ] [ __ ] get out of here
[ __ ]
god damn okay
i'm not dead yet man you're losing your
touch okay so i think i got to get back
to that room which is on the other side
he went to the right
which gives me a straight shot of
getting there
so all i got to do is get gone turn
right and just book it
so he cuz he went the other way or at
least supposedly anyway
unless something horribly got mistaken
and i hear music behind me and i don't
like that
oh god i hope i go the right way the
first time i think it was done this way
no no was it not it was yes because no
it was not
yes it was no it was was it this no it
was oh god no
oh god no how do i do this all the time
oh god oh my god
okay that's great for you hey that's
fine whatever you do
did i check these there's nothing in
here right there would be nothing in
there right
i don't know if i checked these oh
perfect okay that's good okay can i
please get some deadbolt
yes okay we're safe we're good
man i really screwed up
hey i'm gonna talk to harvard you do
whatever what you want you can't do
anything to be
too smart
hello is it harvey
yeah here's a dagger you know anything
about that
stabby stab
[Music]
it's not supposed to be okay but was it
hmm
does that have anything to do with what
you said about the dagger um
[Music]
where is that is that downstairs
oh okay that looked like it was
downstairs i'm not sure let's see if he
pops up
you hear that conversation buddy
that is close oh that is close
that is near and dear okay i'm assuming
that you're not there anymore
i'm really counting on this i'm really
counting on this
and then there's the music and then the
music goes up
he's not there at all no way no hell
all right i'm out of here got music come
back please it's too quiet oh my god
it's too quiet oh god it's too quiet
[Music]
okay cool so uh
oh peek-a-boo
okay well good thing i got a deadbolt
god why does he always have to corner me
in the goddamn worst place as possible
no thank you no thank you no thank you
no thank you try it
try it [ __ ] try it you can't
you're just going to be waiting on the
other side all right i'm going to be
back when i figure
how to get out of here i guess okay that
sounds pretty far away
all right going for it i just need to
get i think i need to go to the ground
floor i think that's what that scry
said but i'm not 100 sure he was very
far away i trust this
i trust this this is trustworthy super
trusty busty
trusty westy trusty wusty trusty westy
was a man
okay trustee westy has a plan
because it looked like uh i don't i
don't know many glass doors
that looked like that other than on the
ground floor
so i'm assuming i'm assuming that it has
to be on the ground floor and if it's
not i'll just cry in the kitchen
and then i'll be away from jimmy anyway
they're going to make this ground floor
not safe at some point
i know that for a fact they're going to
make this not
[Music]
[Music]
hello oh boy
hello oh
no i hate that i hate that hey
what's up man
oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god
[Music]
okay so maybe jimmy did kill some people
maybe jimmy is a bit of a murderer
maybe maybe maybe okay
hey is it harvey hey hey
man sawyer getting stabbed
stabbed backstage weird
behind me
[Applause]
well
see you later harvey
again you did have a gun and you were
threatening to kill him but oh what am i
looking at
ah the great hugo oh
oh i know that hallway that third floor
third floor with the chairs
i got it okay completed rv story all
right bye harvest
hey that was great oh you did have a go
i don't know why i'm trying to give
jimmy the benefit of the doubt here
like jimmy is clearly uh responsible for
many of death
like starting with the little girl so uh
yeah he's not not exactly innocent
there's no
hero villain here it's just
all straight up bad all right so i found
my way to that random chair those two
chairs randomly
many times let's see how long it takes
me now that i'm gonna try to get there
any day now there we go
there we go all right i think it was
left but then again
that might be exactly how i'm wrong hey
where are we at here hello
jimmy are you here no no not that one
white chairs have i seen some white
chairs no
here maybe no
that ah it was the other way
i'm so dumb i'm incredibly dumb
i'm stupendously dumb unless it was down
that other hallway
which it might have been in which case
i'm still dumb
god damn it damn it damn it the one
god damn
it's fine wait that's not it either
is it oh okay maybe it is
no no oh no way
no that's the broken mirrors i already
knew about the broken mirrors
i just i don't know if i hear him
creeping up okay so then what the hell
was
there were two chairs i remember two
chair one two
i know two
the hell is he i should just follow the
arrow why didn't i just follow the arrow
the euro is a clear indication i don't
know i think he's far away
but who knows
alrighty then
okay
so this is fine this is all good
this is all fine hey
what no come on man get out of here
now get out of here get out of here get
out of here come on get you silly get
out of here
[Music]
i don't trust it okay see this is what
happened last time
it went in the bathroom instead so i'm
gonna wait here a little extra long
and then i'm gonna go okay i'm guessing
he's not there unless
oh no no no going back in oh no
i'm doomed it's bull
it's bull honky
ah fine kill me [ __ ] you can't
oh god you can what are you supposed to
do god damn it
it's fine i'm just gonna go and i'm
gonna get
my radio again and i'm just gonna get
i'm gonna get going and you
shut up skip it skip the wake
skip my wake uh
i know i know i know well i want to go
straight but it's not letting me
so i guess i'm not going down that road
well i guess i'm not going anywhere
am i stuck what am i what is happening
i'm going in this room
it's the only thing i can do actually i
just realized
i was supposed to wake up in a room i
was outside of a room well that's not
right
whatever it's fine okay straight let's
just get the thing
and then let's get out of here i went
the wrong
ah i'll be right back okay all right
good
okay here we go we're here again i think
i think i think i think it must be this
way or something i don't know unless
it's
here no i think i should i should just
try the
the compass the compass will tell me
which way i need to go this way
okay good good compass
compassy okay this way okay wasn't this
where i was
wasn't i just in this room
wasn't this the room that i was just
dead in
very noisy this suggested someone's here
it said it here didn't it but the
mirrors that doesn't make sense
okay now i'm just confused now i'm just
confused
what's going on with this cry okay so
it's the mother
it's the mother the madre
[Music]
two
oh i was probably supposed to find the
mirror this is just me
from the first episode screwing myself
in the future
i am future screw no not the bat
what the hell oh my god
oh my god i don't want to go in the hall
[Music]
uh
what what
the hell what
the hell is that
oh this is a normal bathroom now
okay the hell
what the hell
okay all right it's fine that's probably
fine
i'm not gonna worry about that right now
because i definitely have other
pressing concerns like
getting down to the first floor
or was the second god damn it which one
was it god damn it
i know i don't want to mess this up i
think it was first was it
two two two two okay perfect okay
perfect okay
i'm oh my god no wait hang on holy [ __ ]
oh my god i'm going back baby
holy crap oh my god
um okay
oh yeah i'm doomed darn i am doomed god
damn it i did not expect him to be there
holy hell just kill me it was two
was it two i don't remember so many
beatings to my skull i don't even
remember
was it two was it two or one i don't
even remember now
i got i literally just looked at it and
it got exploded out of my face
all right let's just
can i dip no dips i'm not allowed to dip
now
dipping is against the law dipping is
against god
okay no dippies no dippies
that's fine if i could just stop finding
myself in a dead end
oh my god why that doesn't make any
sense oh he must have been waiting for
me
okay got it
weird
so is he gone or what
i can't hear a goddamn thing
all right whatever i'm going for it if
he kills me he kills me but whatever i
just got i gotta go
yeah what's up yo what's up [ __ ]
yeah what's up [ __ ] what's up you want
some of this huh
you want some [ __ ] ah you can't have it
you can't have it was it two or one i
don't remember
i think it was two or was it one
let's go to two ah at least i'm free
okay i'm free which means that we're
moving at least which is nice
uh yeah yay okay so
is the compass spinny spin
oh interesting okay bobby was going to
shoot
jimmy it was just a letter opener it was
self-defense
look hello
hey lady hey lady
lady is someone there someone there
okay so a little distant okay oh wait no
i see i see i see
where are you pointing you in here in
here
hello in here
hello who's that who's there
[Music]
ah well i hate to tell you this but i
think you're dead
this kind of box here either it's
talking to people
pranking me from the other house across
the street or you're dead i saw a lady
explaining that the dagger was a letter
opener
who was she
[Music]
sure yeah maybe i'm
oh
so that's the that's the front door but
i got more questions
oh you gone i have more questions though
is anyone there hello okay well i guess
that was
that was fun while it lasted i didn't
check for jimmy but it's okay
it's all good who cares jimmy what up
what a turd
all right front door down we go
we're getting to the bottom of this
really i think uh jimmy's mom's death is
really gonna put um
put all this in perspective
and prove jimmy's innocence definitely
most definitely that's
that's likely to happen
still nothing what if i turn around what
if i turn around
what if i go down this way and then i
turn around
no okay what if i talk to you
here hello
hmm what if i look at this from down
this hall
if i look from over here peekaboo
what's going on here what's going on
i still don't know what that door is for
i wonder if i'll ever know
clang okay let me scry just in case
but i was j i was just the here here is
where i
just was i swear i was just there
jimmy get out of here you're not even a
part of this you have nothing to do with
this
not a thing i'm an ace detective and
i've been looking at all the information
and you are not even related to any of
this
so get out of here all right hello
all right you know what i'm just gonna
go straight down this way
it's flickering definitively
oh what the hell what the hell what the
hell okay
oh hi hug time
oh no
i'll take it i'll take the hug i need
the i need the emotional validation here
physical connection even with the
skeleton that'd be fine okay um you here
now
is it rose is he rose
[Music]
okay rose so uh first off about the
whole hug
who are you greeting at the entrance in
reception yahoo
does that have anything to do with the
great hugo
the the great the great hugo
a performer announcing himself as the
great hugo
he was a magician and an entertainer
yeah
he
[Music]
[Music]
oh so there's hugo jimmy's father
hugo and then there's jimmy who that
hugo is not so
hugo i heard a man shouting at someone
telling them to do as he says
who was he a big hole in the ground too
that was weird
i never knew what he wanted there was
only one thing i could give him
oh okay okay
um okay so
i saw harvey being stabbed to backstage
yeah harvey that whole thing
yeah what happened
himself
so who does the dagger belong to
it's a letter opener actually it was a
letter opener
it was a present from someone
okay all right i saw harvey with a gun
practicing with it
what was he going to do
[Music]
yeah probably but there's also a lot of
leather openers and swear words around
so
not the not the craziest thing okay so
i found a way of bringing in more guests
i don't know what that is i am going to
go and cry
because that's the only way that i can
not die
hello scry 208
i'm getting a vision that was very quick
okay quick vision 208
all right so we just got to get to 208
real quick real quick
the speed is on get to it
not sure what i'm gonna find there but
at least keeps me moving
really bouncing around you know it might
have been better if i was just at the
beginning of this gone through and found
everything first
and then
now which direction is 28 am i ever
going to be able to find 208
i'm never going to be able to find
anything specific when i want to but
please just let me get to 208 that's all
i ask jimmy
it's all i ask do i ask a lot of you
jimmy no i didn't even ask to go to your
goddamn
show so don't don't make me ask for this
i think that's the way to one and four
it's definitely not that way
what is this that's 206 right okay
that's 206.
okay so 2a must be down this hallway
here
okay
nah sadly no
207 and 208
nailed it perfect i'm great
i don't hear jimmy but i've been
mistaken before
that's candy
hugo punch in his comedy monologues
great
funny unusual the hanging heating
wow this is really great stuff this is
good stuff wow
that's great
um jimmy are you there
found your poster really good stuff
really good stuff pal
really good stuff anyway i'm i'm out of
here don't kill me oh
that sounded a little distant so i'm
assuming i'm okay
oh i'm not okay i'm not okay i have a
deadbolt key for this place
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
okay okay hang on
quick quick quick quick oh my god quick
quick quick quick
oh my god quick there we go
[ __ ] suck on that stuck on that nerd
[Music]
all right fine then all right well done
i'm gonna wait here
a little bit and then oh yeah i'll wait
here a little bit yeah i'll wait
i'll wait okay perfect
perfect that's exactly what i wanted you
to do idiot
fool because i just need to take a right
and then i get out of here
later dickweed see on the other side i
never
bill yo okay this way not that way yeah
going straight i know my way around here
now
ah yeah oh yeah
oh yeah okay going back down oh yeah
oh fool you fully full
you're full you have no idea i've
bamboozled you
i've tricked you
anyway hello hi
uh so um yeah about this whole hugo
punch in the lesser version of the great
hugo
um does that bring any bells
rose is anyone there
[Music]
you sound so sad i don't know why who's
hugo punch
[Music]
okay thank you that was it okay these
combined when you said jimmy found a way
of bringing in more guests
is that connected to what you said about
the hugo punch poster
yes that was jimmy
[Music]
hmm
i'm sure
what am i looking at what what the hell
am i looking at
what the hell was that supposed to be
was that supposed to be something that i
could discern
was that supposed to be something that i
could logically look at
wait why is it so loud
why is it so loud oh no oh
no
okay this is fine
this is fine this is totally fine
oh yeah okay there is something down
there well what is it spit it out
[Music]
that's pretty jazzy you know i'm not
gonna lie that's pretty good
[Music]
all right anybody here is it rice is it
[Music]
so he was actually funny is what you're
[Music]
saying
huh interesting wait you don't have
anything about that it seemed angry
did the broken mirror broken mirror
broken mirror broken mirror
bro broken mirror broken mirror i found
these so
[Music]
is that connected to what you said about
the broken mirrors
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is where the dissociative identity
disorder comes into play
that's third floor definitely that's
also a river of blood flowing before my
eyes
all right interesting okay well that's
lovely thank you for that information 78
complete okay so i'm gonna end this
episode here and then the next episode
is gonna see
this to the end in one shot unless
there's a true ending and then maybe
there'll be another video afterwards but
this is fun
i like this a lot i really like this
style i hope it i hope the developers of
this game make another one very soon
because this is very fun
sorry it's been taking so long but
getting through it thank you everybody
so much for watching
and as always i'll see you in the next
video bye-bye